dans les années 80 et 90 des sangliers
ont été introduits dans plusieurs
provinces canadiennes dont le québec
pour diversifier les élevages
c'est une viande qui est apprécié mais
il faut savoir que la bête a une
capacité d'adaptation hors du commun
une fois en liberté les sangliers se
reproduisent à vitesse grand v et
peuvent causer énormément de dommages
aux cultures notamment ses sangliers air
en pleine nature depuis des mois nous
sommes à l'automne 2010 8 en outaouais
des spécialistes ont bien tenté de les
capturer mais sans succès ce n'est qu'au
printemps qu'ils seront finalement
rattrapé puis abattu
ces échappées montre bien que les
sangliers d'élevage survivent aux hivers
québécois
un constat qui est qui est de plus en
plus les spécialistes de la faune de 2,2
déjà de 12 mois ont passé depuis la
dernière traque en outaouais
ces spécialistes sont sur une nouvelle
piste du mien nous sommes cette fois ci
à durham-sud au centre du québec les
citoyens ont signalé la présence de
sangliers
les biologistes confirment qu'ils sont
dans le secteur 2
les experts veulent maintenant retrouver
l'endroit où les sangliers passe la nuit
afin d'y installer une cage de capture
d'image pour l'objectif est simple
éliminer ces bêtes du milieu naturel
mais la tâche sera ardue
[Musique]
on l'issue des fois là on passe la
journée dessus assure des traces
on n'arrive à rien pendant la journée
d'entre eux de les placer 5 6 7 km dans
une journée pour aux autres c'est facile
c'est ça la ville se déplacer ces
spécialistes compte déjà une vingtaine
d'opérations de captures depuis quatre
ans la technique est chaque fois la même
repérage des bêtes à partage si
retourner les installations de la cage
[Musique]
mais le sanglier rusé une fois un
liberté ils redeviennent méfiant
c'est quand même assez déçu parce qu'ils
ont une intelligence assez développée
ici on le rate une fois ils comprennent
que c'est un subterfuge puis ils
s'approchent pu être autre aux proches
et aux installations faut changer de
technique procédé capturer ou aller à
l'abattage direct mais quand c'est des
gros groupe c on cherche à les capturer
d'un tout d'un coup la menace est réelle
le sanglier est considérée comme une des
espèces exotiques envahissantes les plus
néfastes sur la planète et l'hiver
québécois c'est maintenant prouvé n'est
plus un obstacle à sa survie sont faites
pour ceux qui ont du poids est endiguée
ils sont quatre ils seront déplacés ils
sont des nids six caches son coeur de
trouver une façon pour ce travail
québec déploie les grands moyens pour
éviter que des sangliers ne s'établisse
dans la province comme c'est déjà le cas
en amérique
aux etats unis les porcs sauvages comme
on les appelle sont présents dans 38
états ces ports sont soit des sangliers
échapper d'élevage ou des hybrides issus
de croisements avec des porcs domestique
retourner en nature au texas
on a tout simplement perdu le contrôle
les autorités autorisent maintenant le
tir à vue afin de réduire les dommages
aux propriétés au canada certaines
provinces font face elle aussi à de
sérieux problèmes
ces biologistes de la saskatchewan mène
des études sur la croissance
exponentielle de ses bêtes
la province compte 58 % de tous les
porcs sauvages au pays
l'alberta et le manitoba ne sont pas
épargnés elles sont elles aussi aux
prises avec des populations de porcs
sauvages bien établie au québec la
situation reste pour l'instant sous
contrôle
c'est important de savoir que pour
l'instant de ce conseil a pas de
population établie laissent-ils nier
qu'on va voir dans la nature ces dessins
signés qui sont échappés d'élevage donc
ils sont gardés en captivité qui pour
une raison ou une autre ça sortir d un
autre lot ces animaux là qu'on voit en
nature chaque année le ministère de la
faune du québec rejoint une vingtaine de
signalement de bêtes échapper des
sangliers d'élevage ou des hybrides qui
se retrouvent leur cavale il suffit
qu'un groupe soit oubliée pour que
l'espèce prolifère le singulier c est la
grand-mère une fac et le plus prolifique
au monde donc dans des bonnes conditions
est singulier peut commencer à se
reproduire vers l'âge de 6 mois et avoir
de portée par année deux peut-être six
sangliers à durham-sud les spécialistes
constatent que les sangliers ont passé
la nuit à fouiller ce milieu humide
les bêtes sont en constante recherche de
nourriture
il va se nourrir la plante à fumier des
reptiles couleuvres vont manger aussi
des ennemis peut manger des oeufs
ils veulent qu'on les trouve actuelle
d'europe et ouvrez les yeux de ces
animaux là vont manger des petits même
fort aussi sourit puis ou six pros même
allé manger des carcasses 6 n'aurait
d'animaux qui sont morts
une fois introduit en nature le sanglier
est reconnue pour nuire aux espèces
indigènes et causé d'importants dommages
aux écosystèmes et c'est sans compter
les ravages faits à l'agriculture chaque
année aux états unis
les porcs sauvages entraîne des coûts de
1,5 milliard de dollars en dommages est
en mesure de contrôler
[Musique]
ce champ de maïs et l'endroit retenu
pour installer la cage de capture ici en
train de chance on voit qu'ils viennent
s'alimenter dans un coin enfin sida
partageons la à l'aise parce qu'on a des
vieux signes de présence des nouveaux
signes de présence donc il ya des
chances que les sangliers rendant cette
carte
c'est en 2016 que québec décident de
récupérer tous les sangliers échappé en
nature
cette année-là et biologiste capture un
groupe de sangliers dont une femme elle
en pleine gestation
cette preuve est venu confirmer la
menace
[Musique]
l'animal est capable sera produit en
nature de passer l'hiver a les capacités
pour surveiller donc est capable de
s'implanter puis de cause et d'un match
qu'à cause convoquant le cas dans
d'autres provinces
d'autres auteurs américains puis c'est
ça qu'on veut éviter à tout prix
pour prévenir cette menace la province
suit l'exemple de l'état de new york
les biologistes ont éradiqué avec succès
une population de sangliers qui menaçait
de s'établir
ils ont choisi des cages comme celle ci
et surtout ils ont interdit la chasse
sportive qu'à se sont aperçus ce que
craint que des groupes dans l'abord un
ou deux ces groupes le stand sacré des
nouveaux groupes un peu partout puis
tant est qu'ils sont très fertiles
on le voit les opérations de capture
sont coûteuses pour prévenir les
évasions québec vient de resserrer son
règlement on oblige désormais les
éleveurs à se doter de clôture plus
sécuritaire ces documents étaient des
agents protection font des inspections
ya des coques les codes sociaux n'est
pas de problème mais il ya d'autre part
d'autres clubs plus problématique est
même très problématique qu'il faut
régler mais pour certains éleveurs
ces nouvelles mesures sont trop
coûteuses
l'association des producteurs de
sangliers du québec a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue à la caméra sur ce
sujet ses dirigeants affirment que les
évasions surviennent chez de petits
producteurs qui ne font pas l'élevage à
des fins commerciales et eric leboeuf
est membre de cette association
il a accepté de nous parler en son nom
personnel
cet éleveur voit d'un bon oeil la
nouvelle réglementation une façon dit-il
de responsabiliser tous les éleveurs
on veut surtout pas être pointé du doigt
s'il ya des évasions
donc on veut prendre toutes les
précautions
on est des amis agriculteurs nos voisins
on voudrait pas quelqu'un en vie c'est
un espèce envahissante on voudrait poker
d évasion puis qu'un filet
les récoltes de nos voisins soient
affectés il est de vie comme l'affirment
son association que les échappées
surviennent chez de petits producteurs
mais là encore les éleveurs ont une
responsabilité
le problème c'est quand certains
éleveurs vont vendre les vins individus
monsieur et madame tout le monde qui
veut avoir deux singulier dans son petit
enclos comme on peut avoir deux cochons
dans son enclos puis des damnés les
restes un jardin l'association des
éleveurs
c'est maintenant doté notre code
d'éthique qui interdit la vente aux
éleveurs sans permis
l'état de new york a maintenant interdit
l'élevage de sangliers afin de prévenir
de nouvelles échapper québec n'a pas
l'intention d'interdire cet élevage mais
eric leboeuf veut tout faire pour éviter
une telle mesure
moi je souhaite que la population a pris
six sangliers pour ses bonnes ces bonnes
valeurs et non pour
la mauvaise presse que certains petits
éleveurs des cas isolés font mal
paraître la profession d'éleveur de
saint guy contrairement à certaines
provinces québec peut encore intervenir
pour empêcher que des sangliers ne
prolifèrent sur son territoire car les
spécialistes sont formels
une fois pied des plantes et éradiquer
cette bête est une mission presque
impossible à réaliser
les sangliers se sont méfiés du pillage
installé dans le champ de maïs mais les
biologistes ne baisse pas les bras
au cours des quatre dernières années ils
ont d'ailleurs capturé plus de 80
sanglier à travers la province
la viande est dans bien des cas
valoriser et remises à des banques
alimentaires